good morning hello everyone and welcome
to the apigee online meetup my name is
oliver and i will be your host today
because of the current situation again
we are broadcasting
from our respective homes instead of the
london offices
and we're very excited to have you join
us today
for our conversation
today marks our 10th apogee
online meetup back by popular demand
it is our goal to be as interactive
and as educational as possible
the region we broadcast to is diverse
so i look forward to your perspectives
your comments and questions
throughout today's session
we've got a lot to get through today so
after this introduction
i'm going to give a short introduction
to
running an api first platform
business and then we'll hear from simon
who will talk about driving commercial
impact
with a true platform strategy
well then at about halfway point have an
opportunity
to take questions from you
we'll then roll into our fireside chat
between simon and myself
and then towards the end have another
opportunity
for to answer questions from yourselves
so there's lots of opportunity to ask
questions
throughout this session please don't
just wait towards these windows or
towards the end
of the meet up to ask those questions
please
as we go forward uh something comes to
mind please do ask them in the on
24 tool here today's speaker
i'm very pleased to say that we're
joined today by simon torrance
simon is the creator of the new growth
playbook co-founder of the platform
economy summit
and co-author of fightpack how to win
a digital economy with platforms
ventures
and entrepreneurs so without further ado
get yourself comfortable let's get
started
so to warm things up and get everybody
on the same page
let's talk about api first platform
businesses executing with that platform
mindset
for the digital native platform
businesses like google apis
are in our dna it is how we share data
within the business and outside the
business
there are substantial commercial and
transformative effects
if you execute well i'll touch
on some key examples of business
outcomes our customers
have realized as a result of executing
wealth
now one of the challenges around apis is
the fact that they've been around for
such a long time
people's perspective of them is that
they're about
technology and integration and access
this left-hand side of this sliding
scale
apogee and myself spend a lot of time
helping customers
really think about this from right hand
side where
these substantial effects can be
realized because now a business can
efficiently participate in
vibrant digital ecosystems experiment
launch new business models new ventures
and monetize in new and different ways
the organizations that do this well are
where apis aren't just
in the periphery apis are now central to
everything
that they do this api first culture
so apis are built by default but apis
are just how data is shared
through the business and in and out of
that business
many of you will be familiar with that
jeff bezos mandate in 2002
no less and now that
really launched that api first culture
in amazon
and most industry observers would say
that that was
key to how amazon has shown
extraordinary growth and adaptability
and resilience
as that business has evolved
these are sort of examples where
business realizes network effects
of growth new revenue streams resilience
and adaptability
there are other larger financial
incentives
to to execute a platform strategy
mckinsey believes that
by 2025 so not that far away
60 trillion dollars is going to flow
through digital platforms
denzel lagarda and vol van olstein in
that academic paper
called the impact of apis in firm
performance
talk about a number of benefits
financial benefits to an organization
and the call out there is that they
believe that you can achieve
a 12 increase in market capitalization
if you
execute well now there are more tangible
more immediate business outcomes which
i'll touch on in a moment
so an api platform and strategically
placing that
in the heart of your business enables
you to
control and enable the flow of data
through supply and demand
let's go through supply here so it may
well be that you already today have a
rich catalogue of products and services
perhaps from lots of different parts of
the business you know if you're a large
group
company for many of our customers is
about
aggregating supply from partners and
startups
so for example leveraging another
company's
products and services or indeed content
many of our customers are trying to
interact much more efficiently
with other industries telcos banks
logistics classic examples where a
business now needs to be
very efficiently interacting with other
industries
and of course things at the bottom there
for
particularly like technology companies
smart cities
telcos there's often a huge fleet
of devices and sensors out there and you
need to aggregate
that data and flow into the business
and then demand so again partners
it may well be that a channel for your
products and services
will be strategic partners
it might be the long tail to third party
applications and developers
social channels of which there's always
a new one popping up
every couple of years of course
on the channel and devices of all sorts
and of course mobile channels
so by strategically placing that api
platform
in the middle it enables you to insert
that control plane as data flows
in and out and through the organization
it enables you to govern that data
protect it
but also unlock it where appropriate
package it
productize it and monetize it
now monetization is a key data strategy
and it is often rooted around some sort
of
partner strategy this enables you now to
create these highly reusable assets
these apis
and it enables you to decouple
old and new worlds or different parts
of that demand supply balance that want
to operate
at different speeds simon's going to
talk about this model of supply and
demand a little bit more he's also going
to talk about
innovation models that you can drive
into corporates
apis really help an organization and uh
unlock that innovation whilst also
leveraging those efficiencies of scale
those assets that an enterprise has
data is fundamental here so apis and
this api layer gives you
this unique opportunity in capturing
data consistently
large large volumes of data so it's also
important that you're
capturing that data you're not scared of
the volumes of data
that you are democratizing that data and
you are
giving the different teams within your
business that data
they can drive inside into their
different product areas
this slide emphasizes now this future
state
organizations that they are becoming
orchestrators
facilitators between supply and demand
facilitating highly efficient
transactions
i talked about some tangible
commercial effects that some of our
businesses some of our customers have
have realized so partners
is a key kpi for many of our customers
often coming from a world where
onboarding used to take
years if not several months so this is a
kpi from a telco where they could
increase
the time they can reduce the time to
onboard
from two years to two weeks
now that is an important kpi for anybody
on a journey of of a partner ecosystem
scale a technology company we work with
runs a platform at 10x the scale of
other projects with
one-tenth the workforce because
that platform there gives you a unique
opportunity to facilitate
these large groups of
supply and demand
optionality so it's not just about speed
here it's also the cost
in which to do something so this comes
from a retailer where they could
increase the frequency of digital
channel deployments
by 30 times that meant for example that
they could also
quickly and cheaply launch new
products new offerings digital offerings
to their customers
to validate as to whether those they
were
going to be impactful products in their
own right new call center applications
new mobile applications these were
complex
apps built within weeks
and lastly products and services a
retailer here
increased their product count 10x from
50 000 to 1.5 million skus
product variants and they did that
within the first year
of launching their marketplace the
marketplace being
a type of platform strategy
so these are kind of good examples of
kpis that
excite the business community today
i want to call out two customers that
are really demonstrating this
phenomenally well in the world of retail
magalu magazine louisa
based in brazil and in the world of
financial services
parity which spun out of all states
they also show two very different
examples of driving
innovation within your business which
simon will go into in more detail
magalu reinvented themselves moving from
a traditional world of
uh of a transformation where you're a
physical retailer with omnichannel
they now see themselves as that digital
platform with a physical presence
and all states that had a connected car
program running for many years
recognized that they should spin out
arity so that it could
execute autonomously from their parents
simon will touch those two two types of
innovations
so with magalu this is a an example of a
customer that has realized those market
capitalization increases if you look at
their stock price over the last few
years
this is a business really focused on
those and that partner ecosystem
they used to sell tens of thousands of
schools they now sell
13 million products they have 15
000 sellers on their platform complex
partners
on board with only within only two weeks
apigee helps you onboard those partners
efficiently
and since the last since the last four
years they've seen
between 60 to 70 76 year-on-year growth
in e-commerce with arity
now that connected car program within
allstate
had a vast volume of data
but they recognized that
there were some industry challenges that
they wanted to solve by
unlocking this data and monetizing
their data so
they wanted to better understand risk
and more precisely
price insurance that means they need the
best insights
which means they need the most data so
by
not just using the data from the parent
but opening up
their apis to all sorts of participants
it means that they can
hoover up much more data thereby driving
much more insight through their models
and thereby making a much more
compelling service
with which they monetize they sit on
over 85
years worth of claims frequency and
severity data 10 years of experience
capturing telematics data these sensors
in things like phones and cars 35
billion miles
of driving data built into these models
they partner with mapping companies and
weather companies
customers include financial services
customers transportation
ride sharing companies automakers and
governments
so this is a great example there's a
virtuous cycle of data flowing in and
out of the business
they've even signed up a competitor to
their parent hall state
because they just need more data which
just makes them more valuable
right thank you and now i'd like to hand
over
to simon thanks very much
ollie um very good to be here so
i'm going to talk about really what this
picture shows here and you you recognize
that symbol
um how can we as incumbent businesses
release the inner digital superman
so we can create new growth and value
and we're sort of trapped within the
body of clark kent at the moment
in terms of the ways that we think and
the ways that we act
and our existing business model and what
i'm going to try and show you over the
next 20 minutes is
how we can apply platform thinking and
platform strategy
to create a significant commercial
impact
and create a new way to grow in the
digital economy
a bit of background ollie's already
introduced me i won't go through this
in detail i've written a book on this
topic i work with the world economic
forum
on their accelerating digital
transformation program
and that is again about how to help
leaders
and regulators and government think
differently about the types of business
models that are going to be most
appropriate in a digital world and i
work with
execution partners like rain making a
big corporate innovation company and
venture building company
to help corporates move forward with
these principles
and my experiences across many sectors
and uh
and geographies and i'll touch on
from these during the talk so
the problem is summed up by these
three statistics you can see here
and my contention is that digital
transformation
wasn't making a big impact before covid
vid increases the importance that we
think differently about how we operate
in a digital world
and you can see these three statistics
here from uh surveys of
sea level executives in about about 18
months ago
they were worried that their existing
business models were becoming
increasingly unviable as they're step to
digitize
this because that increases competition
opens up transparency about prices
and as they try and compete with their
or keep up with consumer demands and uh
compete with other players it increases
costs
and in fact 85
of digital investments deliver zero or
negative
economic value add that's the profits
after cost of capital
and as a result of this even before
covid
executives were not particularly happy
with the innovation efforts
of their organization and now we're
under even more pressure
the imperative to really think
differently
and apply new business models is just
even bigger
and if you are an investor i'm sure
all of you are you have your own private
investments
working big companies are also investors
where do they place their bets
what type of business models would you
invest in
compared to others and here's an example
of the returns
of businesses that operate a platform
business model at the top there
compared to traditi i guess more
traditional tech companies in the nasdaq
the dow jones
and if you're a an incumbent
organization from a traditional industry
you tend to be
you're represented by the bottom uh
figure there
so if you're thinking about where you
invest your money either as
private investors or as companies maybe
there are new types of business models
that you should be investing in which
have more resilience
and more potential to grow and my
contention is that
those are platform business models and
every company
needs to fully embrace them if they want
to stay competitive
in a digital economy and then it begs
the question well what do we mean by a
platform business model
and this is a very simple description of
it it's a bit
similar to the one that ollie showed
showing that
platform businesses essentially act as
intermediaries between
people who've got solutions and people
who want solutions
and if you're an incumbent corporation
you provide some of those
those solutions but there are many other
people who could be complementary to you
to create solutions that serve your
customers
and the aims of uh the platform business
are to facilitate high value
transactions not just sell your own
products
um and to create network effects that
mean that your business is more valuable
the more people who use it
that's why ebay and uber and airbnb are
so
powerful they facilitate interactions
and the more people use it the more
suppliers the more consumers
the more valuable it becomes and the key
requirements are that you create an
infrastructure like olly said
enabled by apis is really critical that
anybody can plug into your business
now how that translate if we go
forward oh yes
my technical problem i will let's see if
i hope you can see
a picture of um a tweet by the ceo of
twitter
yes hopefully you can see that ollie can
people see that
i hope so i'm probably not the best
person to answer because i've been
having problems as well but yes i can
see it now yeah
okay okay good so the the key essence of
a platform business is summed up by this
tweet from the ceo
of uh airbnb who said here you can see
it marriott wants to add 30 000 rooms
this year
we can do that in the next two weeks and
it sums up
the essential power of a platform
business model
where you are leveraging the assets of
other people
you don't have to build hotels to be
able to provide
a place for people to stay and
for a incumbent organization there are
many options for where you could play
in a platform economy you could
create your own platform business um
you could uh
supply into platform businesses you
could use platforms to
supply you with services or you could
create enabling
capabilities that you make ability make
available
into platforms uh to help them run
better
it has oddly said 30 of global economic
activity
is going to be mediated by platforms in
five years time
that creates an enormous market for
people who've got who can create
enabling solutions that make those
platforms run better
and financial services is a golden
example of this
to provide financial services to support
platform businesses
so making this a bit sort of making this
a bit
more tangible uh what i've identified is
six main types of platform plays
for corporate businesses and four types
of executional approaches
uh this is really critical because it
helps to translate what can feel
like a very technical topic to senior
commercial execs into something more
tangible
and i'll just describe these quickly and
show you some examples
so at the very very end there you could
reinvent your company entirely and say
we're going to
become a platform business like amazon
did and apple did
20 years ago or you can start
more simply on the bottom left here and
say well
we're trying to create digital solutions
we don't have enough
capabilities and resources in-house to
do that
how could we tap into the thousands if
not hundreds of thousands
of experts who are out there in the
world freelance experts
we could use to help us create product
create new digital solutions
and that would be a very legitimate way
of augmenting your own capabilities
with third parties and there's some
great example i'm going to show you in a
minute of a company who's done that
you can create your own digital
solutions and those would be
software-based products and services
and those most unicorns start off doing
that
and then they evolve into platform
businesses over time
why can't we as incumbent businesses
create our own
unicorn businesses there's no reason we
have all the assets there
there are a few things missing which
i'll describe in a second
and of course you can embed your
products and services or your digital
solutions
into other people's platforms you can
create online marketplaces like we heard
with with magalu
in in south america you can also
orchestrate completely new ecosystems
that are emerging at the boundaries
between
sectors as these boundaries are blurring
there are wonderful opportunities to
create new ecosystems that you can
orchestrate
with a platform and in terms of the way
of executing
the problem that many traditional
companies have is they think we need to
build this internally it's a big it
project and take five years and that's
the wrong approach entirely
occasionally you can do something like
that where you have
um a particular power to do so but there
are other approaches that are
complementary to that
which need to be part of the armory if
you like
so collaborating with startups to help
you speed up
time to market is really really a very
powerful and legitimate way to act you
can
buy in and acquire companies to help you
speed up your activity and one of the
best approaches that i do a lot of work
with today is
creating your own external ventures
outside of the core business
where you can see a market opportunity
like arity we heard from ollie
just now but if we try and create that
within the core business we know it's
going to get suffocated
let's create a separate venture with
separate metrics
new skills hired new talent to drive
forward and effectively to grab that
market opportunity
and that's a particular capability that
is really important now as things are
moving so fast
and here are a few examples of companies
to bring to life some of those
examples i gave you there um so i i
won't go through them all right now
but i'm gonna let's just pick on a few
here but general electric
um it decided it when it was moving to
be a digital
uh company digital industrial company it
said but we just don't have the skills
in-house to
create the products and solutions that
our customers want and they created a
huge marketplace to tap into external
talent outside the walls of their
company
so they could develop products and
services for their customers
very powerful very practical uh platform
strategy
which has delivered about seven billion
dollars of value to the organization
over seven years
i'm going to pick on a few examples of
companies later on
um as i've progressed i just want to
pick on a few
tinkoff bank is one of my favorite
examples of moments from the financial
services sector
and it has completely revolutionized
digital banking has started off being a
traditional bank
and has created a whole series of
lifestyle ecosystems around it
and has the highest some of the highest
metrics for banks in the world today
in terms of return on equity and so on
and so forth
and in the world of embedding
capabilities into platforms
paypal is obviously a great example
there but paypal enables nearly every
global platform for many global
platforms around the world
so let's look at some um examples and my
one of my favorites of a traditional
company that has really embraced
platform thinking
is ping anne which uh was a and still is
an insurance company in china
but these charts you see here represent
how they
shifted or reallocated capital
to the new types of business models that
i've just been talking about in 2008
they were simple
uh insurance company operating with that
type of business model by 2018
they have reallocated capital management
potential
and skill to create a network of
ecosystems
outside of traditional financial
services
in real estate in buying and selling
cars in healthcare remote healthcare
and those ecosystems enabled by
platforms
have helped it have helped it to grow
way beyond their traditional competitors
and i anticipate they do
they'll do more and more of that over
time and their business model portfolio
will involve will evolve even more to be
even more powerful
and you can see here this is uh their
share price over time here
they they're never blue they're now
worth more than europe's
biggest bank hsbc hsbc used to own
a large mistaken thing and it sold that
stake after the last financial crisis
i think i has overtaken them as much
more valuable
and now has become the biggest uh
shareholder independent shareholder in
hsbc
you can see hsbc's trajectory uh
compared to
theirs and indeed they've outperformed
their local competitors
so it's not just a it's not just well
that's china
the business the application of the
business model has helped them out
compete
europe's biggest bank and the local
competitors as well
and the key thing that has driven it is
leadership the leader said
he looked at how alibaba and others were
operating and he said we want to emulate
that
he said we're no longer an insurance
company we are now going to be
a tech company with financial services
licenses and they embrace platform
thinking
and uh they've been incredibly
successful
we'll come back and talk about them
maybe later on today
so what do we what does it mean for
leaders
and traditional companies well i i wrote
a book on this called fight back
and it's as much about fighting back
against old ways of thinking and acting
as it is against fighting back against
digital disruption
and there are five key steps to renew an
incumbent
business model to make it fit for the
future
and particularly in these times of
crisis the imperative to apply these
principles
is really strong the first thing is we
need to reset the way our leaders think
about growth and value most leaders of
incumbent businesses have become
successful operating a certain type of
business model
and the digital business models that
we've been talking about just now
are often alien and different we need to
rethink about
the ecosystems that are emerging and
where we could play
and our roles within that and this comes
back to the way of executing as well we
can't just
try and execute everything from within
the core business we need to
reallocate capital as we heard from tian
in a different way
and put our money where our mouth is if
we really want to be a digital player
and probably the most crucial thing we
cannot
do disruptive innovation from within the
core business
it rarely works we need to create an
ambidextrous two-handed
organization and provide the space for
new digital businesses to take off like
we heard from arity from molly earlier
on
well they have the they can access the
assets of the core business
but they have different leaders
different metrics
uh different space in which they can
operate often
equity based ventures this is how ping
and did it it created separate
equity-based ventures which attracted
a great entrepreneurs to drive them
forward
but connected them back to the core
business and allowed the core business
to control them they weren't
third-party investments and then finally
if we do this
we can like done is widen our scope be
more involved in more parts of our
customers like
and and uh deliver much more value to
them
now i'm going to end with um with one
tip
and a couple of case studies and then
we'll open up for discussion
one of the most challenging things when
you're trying to describe
these types of new business models is
making it tangible for the leaders
of the business units and in the core
business they have all the power
they they they run the business they
have the budgets and they have all the
assets
that you would love to leverage and one
one thing i find very effective is to
sit down with the leaders
of the existing business units and show
how by creating digital platform
businesses
whether they're internal or their
separate venting we can
we can increase the revenue all the core
metrics that are important for the
core business by a significant amount
and we can show how we can do that to
defend their business
create new revenue or other metrics that
are important to them
and here's an example i worked on with a
insurance company to show
over five years how we could create a
material difference
to their business by applying the
practical principles i just described
today
and i'll give you a couple of examples
here how it is possible
for any my belief any business in any
sector
to create a significant new growth path
if they can remove the blinkers and
apply
some of the principles and methods i
talked about and fl smith is a
very large mining company but wanted to
say
wanted to ask itself how do we create 20
net new growth over the next
five years and by applying the
principles i talked about envisaging
new ecosystems and spotting
opportunities
to apply those different platform plays
and the different ways of executing they
identified three billion of new growth
opportunity over the next five years now
the other example i want to share with
you
is a small insurance company that said
we need to
we need to be engaging with millennials
they don't buy insurance they don't look
to the future
we know that they will be most of they
will
make up the majority of the insurance
market in a few years time
how do we engage with them we don't have
the skills to do that and they created
a separate joint venture with
entrepreneurs
a pretty equity structure up an equity
structure
to tackle that market that's been
incredibly successful
and they're on track to for significant
impact to their core business
and they've done it at record speed
something that would be impossible
within the conversation
and then finally probably the best
example
of the ambidextrous organization being
put in place bp
knowing that fundamentally fossil fuels
are under significant threat over the
next
week no one wants possible people
uh 10 20 years they said we cannot
innovate we need to change the way we
innovate it's not it's not making an
impact
they created a separate unit called
launch pad
in which they said we're going to create
five unicorn businesses over the next
five years
five minutes businesses but critically
those businesses need to add five
percent to the ebitda
of our core business as well so they
created a future business metric
and they said to engage the leaders of
the core business
we are going to add value to you over
this period as well we're not this is
not innovation theater
something a long way away from the core
this is about
changing the whole business that we can
be fit
for looking for the future they put
their deputy ceo in charge
um and uh it's one of the best examples
i can see today
of really applying the ambidextrous
approach
and being committed to it so
thank you very much for your attention
this morning and
looking forward to discussing this with
you it's all about how we can release
the inner digital superman from the
wonderful assets and capabilities we
have
which tend to be locked inside our
clark kent which exemplifies
how most businesses incumbent businesses
operate and think today thank you
thank you simon and uh that
really fabulous uh insights shared there
um so this is our opportunity now to
take some
questions from the audience first of all
uh from roland
there's a perspective sorry from your
perspective of working amongst european
corporates do you think too many are
waiting for
or expecting the eu to assist either
financially with innovation
or controlling through regulation as
opposed to corporates actually being
braver
and starting out and perhaps leveraging
a first mover advantage
i think simon you'd be best as that yeah
it's a really good question so
obviously we don't want to wait for
regulators to do anything because that
would be a
recipe for disaster however however
we do need to help regulators create the
right regulatory environments which are
fair and reasonable
and we need to help government as well
create the right industrial
structures for particularly european
uh economy to to thrive and the problem
we have at the moment is that
because traditional european corporates
are not so sophisticated about the
digital world as
uh some of the big digital giants their
lobbying
skills are less powerful
and um so we need to upgrade our our
knowledge of how how digital business
models like the ones i mentioned
operate so that we as industrial
european companies can lobby more
effectively
and help governments and uh regulators
create
more effective uh structures for
innovation to happen
and uh it's quite interesting one of the
the in the financial sector
uh psd2 has been a regulation to open up
uh our data customer data from banks to
allow people to innovate on top of it
and that's created a whole fla a flurry
of wonderful innovation in the fintech
world
and we may well see that type of
regulation applied
to the big um tech giant
who supports them to open up access to
data
that's coming through at the moment
through data portability so
we need to absolutely we need to we need
to take the bull by the horns and
innovate for ourselves
i think we need a more sophisticated
discussion with government and
regulators as well
fantastic and you know a great question
here from
the rotor and apologies if i've not said
that correctly
uh do you always need to have a
visionary leader at the top otherwise
how do you approach making a case for
the investment into a transformation
into a platform business
where the roi is difficult to estimate
and in some business cultures financial
numbers have to stack up front
very interesting and by the way i i was
on a conversation with
a cohort of banking leaders
yesterday and we were talking about dbs
in singapore who
launched 150 apis
as part of their go to market and you
know the position there is that they
don't want to be front and center they
don't want to be owning all these
channels they want to be invisible
and that's their strategy um well and i
can't imagine there was ever a
proposed business case with hard numbers
behind you know something like that but
um simon any sort of yeah well
you're quite right the question is very
good one so sometimes the business does
have a visionary leader
now the danger sometimes is that leader
can be too visionary
and if they don't pull along with them
the shareholders
and the rest of the organization that
can cause a lot of trouble
um in the case of ping and the leader is
a visionary
and he's he's the founder of the company
he's an entrepreneur
so for him he's got that power like jeff
bezos to make things happen
but most uh you know traditional
industrial companies
don't necessarily have that um in place
and we tend to have what we might call
caretaker managers who are very
successful
operators of existing business models
and
uh their job tends to be very focused on
what the
shareholders or the pension funds are
acquiring from them
so we do need a a one we need some
parallel activity we do need a new
discussion with the shareholders to
allow us to do
new things but probably first we need to
prove
uh that this that new business models
can deliver value
and and that's why i was saying before
one of the good techniques is to
is to work with the existing business
leaders to show
how the the platform activity
can deliver a meaningful impact and and
that is
you know that's a that's a difficult
thing to do but it can be done
and it's quite it's an important part of
the process
now occasionally you might say well you
know it's a no-brainer to do apis
and i think that is correct because it
can facilitate so many things and it's
not a huge cost
um but to really get the organization to
move forward you need to have a sort of
grown-up discussion
showing practically how platform
business models can affect the
the core metrics and indeed one of the
best ways of doing that is to do
is to create external ventures where you
can fast track something quickly into
the market
and that demonstrates the art of the
possible you know we've now done it
three times
like the example from the danish insurer
there uh we've created this venture
and already it's worth a lot of money
it's delivering a lot of value
wouldn't it be great if we could do ten
more of these and
uh and that demonstrates the art of the
possible
helps the leaders of the core business
become more confident
and it's something they can show to the
shareholders uh to illustrate what can
be done
fantastic um so
let's try chats uh between ourselves but
i am keeping an eye on these questions
as they flow through and i'm going to
lean
on some of these because they're they're
spot-on and i think
that point about executive leadership
but also proving
um is is is like or always hot topics i
mean i think it
even pre-covered right um
uh there's another question actually
about you know quick wins from a
platform strategy i think you've kind of
touched on that you know how to
demonstrate something relatively quickly
within
and this this individual is asking um
between threats is you know pretty tight
one of the things i've certainly learned
is
you know a lot of businesses are already
trying to work efficiently or more
efficiently with partners
um so perhaps not don't perhaps you know
let's not
focus on unknown innovation first let's
perhaps
think about what are the who are the
honestly working with or work with
imminently
and let's do this in new and interesting
ways and and there i think you know more
more immediate things can be be shown at
pace i mean
some in any reflections on that comment
well you can but that's sort of
incremental i mean
that that's it's necessary but
insufficient it's not going to move
you know you've seen i've showed the the
share prices of the dax it's the same
with the ftse all incumbent businesses
are not doing well the ones that are
doing well that are the ones that have
invested in platform business models and
apple and amazon didn't start out with
that they added it
to their business model 10 or 20 years
ago
so you know absolutely you need to be
more efficient you need to
improve the way you serve your existing
companies and optimize your existing
business model absolutely that's
critical but if you don't do the other
thing the other part of the ambidextrous
activity
you're just in a in a race you know with
your competitors
getting nowhere i mean so you do need to
do both of these things
and rather than put virtually no
investment on on this side
or a tiny bit of let's throw a bit of
money to the innovation team
like bp has done you need to say right
we're going to put 500 million here
to create five unicorns while also
driving
the cool metric which is the ebitda
margin
and that is a very bold and the most
appropriate approach
doing both activities and committing to
both at the same time
and with launch pad
so significant ambition there but it are
any of those
ventures likely to erode
any of the existing uh relations i think
one of one of the challenges i've often
seen is that
classic innovators dilemma where um you
know
there's a new new venture being proposed
there's there's
certainly interest and and excitement
around it but there's concern
that ultimately it's going to disrupt a
you know a revenue line that actually
might be quite profitable
even when they know that that revenue
line is you know potentially at risk if
not
at risk yeah so it's a very good
question and particularly
in in the retail sector when retailers
think about creating online marketplaces
you know which is essentially allowing
third parties
maybe competitors as well to sell
through you to your customers
and even amazon have this debate
internally should we open up to third
parties
rather than buy in the inventory
ourselves and sell it on
and uh they they had the foresight to
look ahead
and said well what do our customers
really want let's think about our
customer
not about us and our customers want
choice and select
and we we can't we don't have the the
money or the the
the capability to provide everything for
our for our customers ourselves so by
looking ahead
focusing on what customers needed and
understanding how the internet and
digital technology could enable that you
know through apis 20 years ago as you
said
they sort they said well let's let's
believe in this vision
and make it happen now in practice how
you execute that needs to be done very
carefully
and the the third party partners or
complement
complementary service providers you
choose to start with you might choose
those that are not directly competitive
and over time
as you're growing the knowledge and
skills of how to curate a marketplace
then you might open up further and
that's what a lot of the
the second wave of traditional retailers
have learnt about how to do
so yes there is a potential threat
of cannibalization but it can easily be
managed if you think it through
um properly and indeed in the case of bp
none of those businesses are threatening
the the core business in fact as i said
they're they've been explicitly set up
to drive understand ebitda improvement
to the core business
so it's it's the actual opposite that
the design
specifically to deliver that value there
as well as separate value for themselves
great thank you and you talked about uh
the value that incumbents uh
might be sitting on um
the danger i guess is that there can be
uh an
ego around the brand um and you know
actually i just talked about that
mention just mentioned that example of
dbs where they want to be invisible i
mean
that's quite an extraordinary statement
for you know a bank to make where
often they want to be front and center
you know the br the brand is a
compelling gravitational pull
everybody wants to kind of own that
relationship with a customer
um what what do you think are the assets
for an incumbent and what are the
liabilities for an incumbent
when thinking a platform strategy yeah
it's a very good question so again what
you need to do is have a vision of the
future
so if you don't have that and you're
always looking
at the present or the past and trying to
extrapolate from the past
then you tend to be trapped in the
mindsets which are not going to be
helpful
so as you say banks often say we want to
own the customer relationship we want
it's our ego we want everybody to come
through us
for conservatives and that's pretty
dangerous that's pretty dangerous
if as opposed to that you look into the
future
and for example you see that
in five or ten years time platforms are
going to be
are going to be mediating 30 of all
economic activity
at 60 trillion dollars so rather than
you trying to compete with people who
are much better at
managing customer relationships like dbs
has done
you say why don't we enable it why don't
we embed
our capabilities into other people's
businesses and in fact just just this is
one example
the market for what's called embedded
finance
so that's financial services embedded at
the point of
purchase you know if you if you want to
go on a
you get an online mba you want to get a
loan right there and then
that can be given to you there and then
without having to call up bank and
transport it out
or you're seeing more of this in terms
of you want to buy a product
but you you want to pay for it in
installments over 12 years
over over a year and this market of
embedded finance
i did some analysis of this the other
day it is potentially
more valuable than the whole of the
global software market
in five years ten years time because
everything has been
everything that's an explosion of
digital services
and we all need to pay for them or
exchange value related to them
and so it's a clever move by dbs to say
actually
we can see this future and we want to
enable it
being in the background rather than
trying to compete
with companies who are much better at
controlling the
customer interface now that that is
that's one strategy
ping-an has taken a slightly different
strategy and both of these
can be complementary if i was you know
if i was talking to a bank i'd say do
do both ping anne said we want to
create deeper relationships with our
customers so let's create
some platforms and ecosystems in areas
of their lifestyle that we normally
don't
participate in terms of in terms of
buying and selling
cars let's create a marketplace for that
or
a remote healthcare telemedicine
platform which is now which is obviously
taken off like
crazy with kovid and they created these
separate ventures
just for the opposite reason of dbs to
be so they could be at the center
of those experiences and those could act
as a channel for their
financial services but interestingly
they created separate brands for those
because they knew that those brands
needed to be
you know people didn't affiliate ping on
with buying and selling cars and so on
so they created separate entities
separate brands they control them
some of those they've ipo but they've
created as a result this
incredible network or ecosystem of
platforms that are all connected by
single one single sign-on mechanism and
an api structure behind it
that allows them to intermesh across all
of it
that's probably one of the best examples
of of uh tackling the question you just
answered you just asked that
yeah fabulous and i i often like that
example also from arity where they are
now signing up competitors to their
parents
because the the they really they've
recognized this for years but you know
more data
means they can provide more insights it
means more value which makes them just
more compelling this kind of
gravitational pull flywheel effects
around data and i guess we
often talk about data being the new
world it's a cliche but it's it's that
combination of data
and you know and and models so ie the
the the automatic insight being
generated out these vast
amounts of data is going to be uh their
um defensive wall as they open up and
and emerge into all these other
different uh touch points and
in industries and i think perhaps one
more question for me and now i'm keeping
an eye on on the
audience questions um so
this is a challenging time for obviously
many industries um you know we've
just been actually working with a
retailer that's seen 90 drop in their
revenue
um but they recognize the importance of
that api strategy
as a defensive and an offensive uh
uh tactic um i often feel like there's
this sweet spot
for an income incumbent so it has
appetites
um so there's uh if there's too much
kind of competitive pressure
uh they can default to safety and if
there's not enough this other end of
scale
they're kind of epic uh
now does this situation know i guess you
know a lot of things being shaken up
um what what do you think will be
compelling messages
uh to that that our audience could take
away around
um this situational awareness that we
currently have this
kind of landscape that we have where so
many of industries have been disrupted
what do you think could be like the
three things to call out that would be
compelling messages
uh going forwards yeah i think one of
the most useful things to do at this
time of crisis is to
spend a little bit of time zooming out
and zooming out from all the all the
pressures of the core business
and looking to the future because the
crisis is what accelerating
digitalization as we know
and certain sectors more than others and
if you've got a you know i one of my
colleagues gave this great
you know he gave his great suggestion
the other day he said why don't you just
apply
4.1 of your employees to look at the
future
now that can be like 40.
can you afford 40 people four of them
could be on furlough really doing
nothing
we're looking for the future because if
we don't do that
we're acting blind it's like walking
forward without
knowing what the future is like and we
need to ask the difficult questions
you know is how quickly is cash gonna
disappear
if you're in financial services or
retail that's a really critical question
um if you're a retailer you know
if you don't have an online marketplace
which is a type of platform
how are you going to compete with others
that have got that and if you did have
it in the covid crisis you'd be doing
really well like
like those that do so
spend allocate it's it's not much
but a allocate some people
to look into that future and translate
it
for the leaders of today so they can
really understand it and internalize it
and everybody's got enough resources
resources to do that that would be the
one
most important thing to do and
understand the business models that are
likely to be most
effective in that world which will be
those that connect people together
platform-based business models
and then try and translate what that
means to the core business
and look at those different types of
platform plays i described
and the different ways of executing them
and create a plan
that can apply those to our business and
finally make it tangible to the existing
business owners
so if we do this like bp has done we we
expect or we will plan for
this type of impact on the core business
as well as
keeping up with the future in the
if you like the invent the future part
of the business
fabulous that resonated with um some
reading i was doing around the companies
that struggled
after the financial assist and those
that actually did
reasonably well after the crisis and it
was interesting to reflect that
those that did kind of broadside
horizontal cost cutting
and didn't invest in in these specific
opportunities
um were like three times less
successful um than than those that
took an opportunity to do sure cut costs
in certain areas but
also um think about the future
and okay so um
we're coming up towards the end so let's
move to uh just another
slot for its uh q a um
here's a question i mean a bit of a
classic and i think we touched on some
of this already but
i mean how did how do you position a
platform strategy in a traditional
company ico and the board down
are very conservative
well you've got to spend time with them
it's like any type of education
make it tangible to them and show how it
can impact
the figures or the numbers that interest
them
so again i go back to that chart with
the insurance companies saying
your current growth plans show this
trajectory or maybe you know in this at
the moment it's a negative
and here here if you did these things
here
we believe it can deliver this and
that's the type of
interesting discussion you have if you
just do it on theory and ideas and
concepts that they've never heard or
they you know they're not familiar with
then it tends to go in one ear and out
the other so we need to make it tangible
for those types of people
and put it in language that is
motivating for them
thank you um great um
i'm just sorry i'm just getting the
questions here uh
yeah okay um i guess um
if i can be allowed to perhaps another
one um
what what kind of platform
types do you think are resonating
with the city suites that you're talking
to
right now i mean you talked about let's
say markets and external
marketplaces and like external like
ventures
what do you think are completely
compelling right now
yeah so it's a very good question it
depends on the sector so
if you take retail if you don't have a
marketplace
an online marketplace you're just not
able to compete
when your customers want something and
then they can't find it on your
on your on your site they go they
default back to amazon of course
so if you're in retail just just being
in the game
means you need a marketplace but that's
i mean that's
just to be in the game what uh
what i think is relevant for all sectors
is to
often people think about platforms as
being let's create the uber or airbnb of
our sector
that's really difficult and most of
those fail
a better starting point when you say
let's create a digital solution
that solves a really big problem for our
customers
and if we if we design that right it can
be a point solution to start with but
like a software business
it can evolve into more of a platform uh
open platform over time but that tends
to be the way that the
the um the unicorn businesses started
out they solve a particular problem
first
and then they expand and i would
recommend for most companies
in those sectors is create a portfolio
of those that's what bp is doing at the
moment
they're not trying to create the uber of
energy way too complicated
some very practical digital solutions
that can be
that are gravity that are addressing a
big big problem in the market
that can also drive value to the core
business and that would be my
my single biggest recommendation if you
remember the types of platforms i talked
about
the bottom two are probably the best to
start with
if you're in financial services think
about embedded finance if you're in
retail
you need a marketplace to be in the game
but you need a combination of those
things
and you need a separate organization in
which to build them
thank you simon and what i love about
that is there's the message uh mckinsey
recently in an article about
digital transformation the time of
crisis talks about the mandate to be
bold
so i think that's a great place to end
today's session thank you
for everyone for the questions today i
hope you found that
session both helpful interesting and
useful
we would also love to hear your feedback
on this event so please do send your
ideas
and suggestions to the feedback link
here
do stay tuned our next online meetup
will be in september
so please share your thoughts so we can
make the next edition
even better thank you for your time i
look forward to seeing you
next time